Tomorrowland is directed by Brad Bird
and stars George Cloney
and Britt Robertson and I'm going to
tell you the plot of this movie without
really telling you the plot of this
movie because the trailers don't really
tell you anything they kind of give you
an idea of what the film is about and
the whole film is a mystery box in that
way and a mystery box is where you have
this item this thing in a movie and you
don't know what it is and the entire
film you're trying to figure out what it
is it's a mystery box filled with
surprises
hopefully that's that that really
fizzled out I was trying to make that
cool and it didn't work
basically Tomorrowland is a place in
which certain people are invited to go
and our main hero played by Britt
Robertson starts to get these visions
whenever she touches this pin of this
area George Clooney is a person who
knows how to get there and she has to
find him to figure out what this place
is and why they need their help no I was
so excited to see this movie because I
am a humongous fan of Brad Bird he is
one of my favorite directors not only
was his animation fantastic with Iron
Giant ratatouille
The Incredibles but his premiere into
live-action with ghost Protocol was
fantastic and so I was so excited to see
that same type of seamless direction
those thrills that he was able to
achieve with that movie and with this
movie he absolutely proves that he is a
master behind the camera when it comes
to direction with action with science
fiction with suspense with building
great set pieces and awesome action
scenes he really understands what he's
doing behind the camera this is a
beautifully directed movie and it's by
far the best aspect of Tomorrowland the
performances are also off the chart
Britt Robertson finally in this movie
shows me what she can do because in the
longest ride she was fine but she was
burdened with a terrible screenplay with
this film she really is able to explore
the depths of her character and not only
is the action really well done but
there's lots of humor in this movie and
she did a great job with that as well
and George Clooney was also very good in
this movie and I like the fact that he
subverted some of his playboy tendencies
he has when he chooses characters like
his Danny ocean type character because
in this movie you actually do get the
sense that he's an older guy who's a
grumpy cranky guy and once you
and things about his character you
understand why he feels that way and his
character also had a lot of great hidden
things about him that really made you
care for him and really made you curious
about what was going on behind that mind
of his and he also had excellent
chemistry with Britt Robertson I thought
they worked very well off one another
another really good performance in this
movie and possibly a star-making
performance is this little girl in the
movie her name is Raffy Cassidy I
believe it's how you pronounce it I
won't tell you much about her character
because I don't want to spoil anything
but she was really great from this movie
a performance way beyond her years so
what I really did like about
Tomorrowland is that it is a very
original movie for years in fact decades
I constantly see critics myself included
complaining that there's no originality
left in Hollywood that movies are just
the same over and over again rehash
plots we have here a movie that is not a
sequel it's not part of a franchise and
it's not a reboot Tomorrowland is a
wholly original and unique movie and it
has an extremely creative vision and I
have to give that praise and I think
some critics are missing that because
after this screening I heard tons and
tons of complaints and no one was just
saying the truth this is a very
different and original movie it's its
own thing it's a script thought up by a
few different people and that is to be
praised this is not a superhero movie
this is not a sequel it's not a spin-off
from a television series or something
Tomorrowland is a creative and unique
film that being said the third act
really derailed for me and again no
spoilers but it was very disappointing
to me to see the way the main villain
was revealed how that all came into play
and of course the overall message and
thing that had to be done to avoid
something tragic was just so cliched and
very preachy and it did not work for me
at all it felt like a complete u-turn
from the type of film we were
experiencing before I appreciate the
message that is being promoted it just
didn't work in this movie for the movie
they were making it felt 100% like a
complete turnaround from everything that
had already happened and it really made
the rest of the movie not as good
unfortunately
the journey in Tomorrowland was so much
fun filled with a lot of awe and Wonder
great weapon design and amazing scene
construction really great humor and
original plot and good performances and
Brad bird remains a fantastic visual
filmmaker I definitely recommend
checking out Tomorrowland but those last
20 minutes really did not work for me
and they may not work for you but you
may be fine with it check it out and see
it for yourself
I'm gonna give Tomorrowland a B+ all so
I really hope you check out my review I
just did for collateral it's one of my
favorite movies and I went all out with
the costume my wife helped me recreate
the look of Vincent it was a lot of fun
it's on my channel right now I hope you
guys check that out also I want to give
a big thank you to my buddy josh mokuba
who runs the casual mafia youtube
channel and does his between the sheets
show because he was the person who made
the call to get me into this screening I
got to see with my buddy Kristian
harloff of schmoes know so I want to
thank both of them because I was in LA
at the time and without those two guys I
wouldn't have been able to see the
screening I got to meet Brad Bird and
shake his hand and tell him how much I
liked Mission Impossible 4 so that was
cool thank you guys and as always thank
you so much for watching guys if you do
see the movie let me know you think of
it below thank you once again and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
Oh